le coup de coeur des yeux d'elsa cette
semaine c'est comme tous les ans pas un
film mais un genre de film le cinéma
d'animation qui est fêtée tous les ans
en octobre cette année pour la quinzième
année consécutive
il y a donc en france la fête du cinéma
d'animation on y participent comme tous
les ans et cette année on fait un
week-end spécial pour les enfants ce
week-end donc le samedi 15 octobre avec
un premier une première expérience au
cinéma prévue pour les très petits
enfants dès 2 ans qu'on appelle pour
appeler une sorte de ciné biberon avec
un petit atelier un temps d'accueil et
des films spécialement choisis pour eux
l'après-midi ce sera pour n'est un peu
plus grand avec un programme qui
s'appelle les petits géants
donc tout ça c'est ce samedi 15 octobre
et puis on poursuivra la célébration du
cinéma d'animation avec un film qui nous
tient beaucoup à coeur dont on espère
qu'il aura un grand succès on l'a en
avant première le samedi 29 octobre à 18
heures au cinéma les yeux d'elsa en
présence de son réalisateur sébastien
laudenbach alors sébastien laudenbach
encore inconnue aujourd'hui mais dont on
va entendre parler avec ce film là c'est
quelqu'un qui est un peintre il
travaille tout seul quasiment ce film-là
n'a quasiment pas eu de financement et
donc comme il avait envie de le faire il
a décidé de le faire tout seul
juste en manipulant ses pinceaux il nous
en dira plus donc le 29 octobre où vous
pourrez voir avant tout le monde
le film la jeune fille sans mains de
sébastien laudenbach au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa
comment se fait-il qu'une fille ces
jeunes rejoignent le fond de mon lit
es tu là pour mourir au contraire je ne
désire rien d'autre que de vivre il y
avait des poires je voulais justement
j'ai une les droits sont dans son verger
le verger dans un jardin ce jardin est
celui dans prince tu n'es donc pas ici
par hasard